what would Vin Diesel to no regrets no
fan
you think how many kind of fast so we
just solved the Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles out of the shadows movie and
early screening of that I'm Justin your
time I'm tae we're in this weird awkward
like talking phase where there's no
cameras around this at all whatsoever
it's just us you and me right here and I
think that teenage mutant turtles was
filmed a lot in that same way where
there was kind of an awkward talking
phase and they didn't realize there were
cameras around them no most of the time
was just a green it was like a narrative
story that we got to experience
firsthand while eating popcorn
I enjoyed out of the shadows much more
than the first movie so you didn't see
the first movie you know - this
completely cold yes the first movie was
essentially a self-serious
origin story that didn't need to be told
because we already know where they come
from we you don't really care and they
go into way too much depth and try to
give these characters meaning and depth
that doesn't exist talking to in your
human nerd and out of the shadows throws
all of that away and just makes this a
Saturday morning cartoon and that's what
I think I appreciated most about this
particular movie was that there was no
you know BS origin story we know where
these things come from we don't care
about it it just starts with them off
like overlooking the Manhattan skyline
eating pizza and then you get right into
fighting yeah like the turtles come out
there swinging they're like it's just a
fun kind of silly way over-the-top
ridiculous martial arts from these CG
characters but something that really
stood up for me was Stephen Amell who's
playing Casey Joan Casey jumps no
explanation whatsoever the guy reaches
in his trunk he has a hockey mask he has
a stick and like he just goes to town
and beaten the [ __ ] out of people and
he's really good at it like Stephen
Amell of course from arrow Fame is a
great martial art like I love watching
his choreography and these kinds of
things and and that's why actually I
think I appreciate the most about this
movie I do like to fight choreography
John Valera was the fight coordinator of
this entire movie he's done things like
300 as a stuntman he was flight he was
the fight coordinator for John wick my
only complaint really was when the Foot
Clan is fighting like people like Will
Arnett's character and then he just did
a to get their asses kicked because
they're just dumb bumbling
at that point you just like you don't
believe in that [ __ ] that's what makes
this a cartoon is that these Foot Clan
you have you have an entire army of
people who have I would assume dedicated
their entire life to martial arts and
kicking ass and Will Arnett can come in
and just like knock some guy sideways
Casey Jones has a hockey stick and
knocks people out with a hockey puck
like they're just Saturday morning
cartoon it hurt to do fall over
it is very cartoon like I mean that like
going down the trope line of like the
angry police chief who's mad at Casey
Jones I guess he's a cop in this he's in
and and I don't really know the orders
of sort of Casey Jones but whatever it's
like all that they they talk to
themselves like they're like wow maybe
he did this no I bet they went that way
you know and then at one moment they're
like on a plane to Brazil it didn't know
and then the bebop and Rocksteady stuff
was great they were huge in the cartoon
I think for the nostalgia factor and
paying homage to the cartoon in this
series they hit the mark on the
cheesiness on the corniness but it
doesn't try to take itself too seriously
it's it's very self referential like
they know what they're doing like they
even had like little cameos from like
Carmelo Anthony and Alessandra Ambrosio
who were just randomly in there you know
if I will on that side and then you had
like the vanilla song it was a nostalgia
trip in so many ways and as horrible as
the acting is particularly for Megan Fox
like she fit so April O'Neill's so well
but she was so much less of a real
character than the completely CG turtles
and Rocksteady and bebop through the
entire film I loved Rocksteady and bebop
they were so much fun they would like
they were very affectionate to each
other and really stupid ways like they
were in the cartoon they were like two
big bros you know and we gotta keep our
eyes out for intruders
well what do intruders look like anybody
that's not a big pig on
Rhyno and you know what the fact is like
we didn't have to go into some crazy
origin story about why their bebop and
rocksteady you know we had Tyler periods
and that scientist and this mean for
God's sake they like made them into who
they are there doesn't need to be in the
exposition you don't care about the plot
holes and I always feel like that's the
sign of like a good kind of fun action
flick you just don't give a [ __ ] about
the plot holes you couldn't care about
the plug if you've thought about the
plot for any amount of time you have
your brave add or you know yeah and I
thought that that was it I thought that
adding those two elements you're right
the stars of this movie or all the CG
characters I want to like attribute some
of the bad acting just to the shitty
script that I think that a lot of those
characters have because I don't think
Stephen Amell is a bad actor I don't
even think Megan Fox is that bad of an
actress I just think that what they had
to work with this crap and that's just
because Kara's you're here to see the
Turtles and Will Arnett of course stole
his scenes it kind of a weird role
bringing him back because he was the
person who got to take credit for the
turtles destroying Strether in the in
the previous movie and this time around
he kind of plays a braggadocio character
who who is the pony bad guy it's silly
and it's phony but and it shows so much
how that how the movie is over-the-top
that he's even believable is this kind
of character like it's a movie that the
first movie should have been it has its
tongue firmly in its cheek you know that
nobody on that film is like I'm making
the next Citizen Kane like no no they
know this is a silly popcorn movie
you're gonna see once and it's just fun
Saturday morning cartoon company
Mikey clear alright play good
you know I I I thought it was funny I
thought it was very light-hearted I
don't think it took it so seriously at
all and I'll think you should have it
all whatsoever and it was a dumb fun
flick and it's a movie that obviously
sets itself up for another sequel I
think the true power of this is do you
want to see another one would you go and
see another Turtles movie after seeing
this I don't think they need I mean I
guess it will depend on how much money
this movie makes you know I don't think
we need another turtles movie there's
gonna be another one but I'm sure
there'll be another one I mean obviously
again like I said I mean no one dies in
this movie by the way like this is made
for kids this movie is made for kids it
kind of makes me think about that the
cartoon like in the cartoon the foot the
foot soldiers were actually robots they
weren't even like live humans because I
think they were worried about parents
freaking out about turtles beating up
people so like they were just robotic so
I if this movie does well with kids
which I'm sure it will this weekend I
yeah I'm sure they'll make another one
you know do I do this another one no I'm
good I'm fine I don't think I'd watch
this movie again but I'm probably watch
a sequel it's renewed my faith in the
turtles as this kind of silly fun
property that is both fun for kids fun
for adults yeah I think I think taking
your kids to see this would be great
again like I said there's like the
violence is even cheesy as hell you know
like I think one point Will Arnett jumps
off a ship container and knocks over
like a Foot Clan soldiers it's just like
yeah I'm awesome you know I mean it's
very goofy like that you said like
yourself cartoon all the way and Kelvin
looking cut